Fox News National correspondent Griff
Jenkins is down at the Border in Eagle
Pass with Texas Republican Congressman
Tony Gonzalez hi Griff
hey that's right and there have been
more than ten thousand apprehensions
just in the Del Rio sector since I have
been here since a new fiscal year began
on October 1st Congressman your thoughts
why are you here today this is the eye
of the storm you know Eagle Pass has
been a Non-Stop chaos from day one I did
a ride along with the Eagle Pass police
department and what we were seeing is
Stash House after Stash House right
across the border they're seeing an
increase in the number of fentanyl
related calls this is happening all over
my district but Eagle Pass is at the
center of it Congressman yesterday
Governor Abbott was really touting
operation Lone Star some 311 000
apprehensions just by Texas DPS in 337
million lethal doses of fentanyl as we
head into a fiscal new year are we
better off or is it getting worse I've
seen it getting worse I mean it is it is
literally all hands on deck from local
PD to the sheriffs the county sheriffs
to the state but this is a federal
problem you know Joe Biden has caused
this problem we have Kamala Harris who's
in Texas later on today for a
fundraising event I mean it's a slap in
the face to the people that live along
the border you know there's a there was
a case I was listening I was having
lunch with uh the one of the sheriffs
from Zavala County and he was telling me
how there was a a child that had a isn't
was in a baseball game and got hit in
the head and he was supposed to get
airlifted to San Antonio for care but
there were no resources because
everything was put towards the migrants
we just had yesterday Congressman we
were showing our viewers uh ambulances
had to take 10 nicaraguans who had been
in a car accident on that side they were
able to cross the river but then of
course border patrol had to jump into
action this is what an America last
agenda looks like everyday Americans are
put last that we don't feel safe we
don't feel secure our children are going
into lockdown we just started up school
a couple months ago a lot of my schools
are going into lockdown on a regular
basis this is not normal there's nothing
normal about us Biden and the house
Democrats have failed US House
Republicans have a plan our commitment
to America part of that is to secure the
southern border how will Republicans
even if you take the house and that's
the only branch of government you have
how will you make a difference the
cartels congressmen seem to have
absolute control of this border here
yeah no right now the cartels have taken
a 500 million dollar smuggling industry
in 2018 to a 13 billion dollar industry
we have to gain control of our country
again House Republicans can do that with
the power of the purse I sit on the
Appropriations Committee it's time for
House Republicans to lead and hold this
Administration accountable then number
one thing that we need from the
administration is just to enforce the
laws that are already on the books
congression we've been reporting on a
tick tock video verified by Texas DPS
advertising for a driver to drive from
McAllen to Houston seventy thousand
dollars cartel's taken to social media
Griff what I'm seeing is the cartels are
are Contracting it out to uh gangs and
organized criminals and those gangs are
subcontracting it out to Everyday People
so that Tick Tock video may have been
seventy thousand dollar advertisement
but the cartel may be giving them 150 in
order to do that why because if
something goes down you're seeing
everyday people get impacted I asked the
sheriff the other day I was like what
does a Smuggler look like and he goes
Tony it's Everyday People now he goes
just in the past month they caught five
National Guardsmen that were caught
smuggling as well well not getting any
better here Congressman Tony Gonzalez is
going to be also meeting with some
business people and I believe a family
member a grieving parent from fennel
Congressman good luck thank you for
being in here we'll send it back to you
Alicia
Griff Jenkins in Eagle Pass Texas thanks
Greg